les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines doivent
s'adapter face à ce deuxième confinement
comme pour le premier un service de
drive s'est mise en place depuis samedi
7 novembre les adhérents vont sur
internet pour réserver en ligne jusqu'à
cinq documents par carte
puis ils viennent les récupérer
directement à la médiathèque de leur
choix on a réussi à conserver le système
de réservation volante d'une médiathèque
à l'autre ces terres que un adhérent
peut faire sa réservation sur un
document du canal ou d'anatole france et
le faire venir ici au 7 mars
voilà à partir de là comme d'habitude
quand leur soit on envoie un mail
les adhérents viennent nous chercher sur
les heures d'ouverture la médiathèque 17
mar à elancourt est ouverte en drive le
jeudi de 15 heures à 18 heures et le
samedi de 10h à 12h et de 15h à 18h
livres dvd ou encore cédé vous pouvez
très bien venir chercher des documents
comment rapporté une fois rendu les
emprunts seront mises en quarantaine
pendant trois jours ce service de drive
permettent à la médiathèque de maintenir
son bon fonctionnement
c'est bien pratique surtout en période
de confinement quoi pour moi c'est
primordial à la bibliothèque c'est mon
lieu de récréation si je peux dire bon
je préfère y aller évidemment pour
choisir moi-même mais là qu'on ait pu
avoir cette possibilité là de rhj
loisirs des ouvrages afin peu importants
je suis venu voir chercher un dvd en
plus en rendez vous même si c'est à des
créneaux restreint mais c'est bien
certaines médiathèque s'organise sur
rendez-vous comme celle du canal à
montigny le bretonneux ou du château à
plaisir dans ce cas il faudra réserver
un créneau horaire par téléphone ou dans
la rubrique agenda de l'aïs médiathèque